Are you insane?
White, British and she's a salesman's daughter.
My grandfather was a king, I am his heir.
I have a responsibility to return home to my people...
...but I will never achieve anything worthwhile if I leave my heart here.
I am the government's representative in Southern Africa.
The policy of apartheid, do you know this word?
If you choose to marry the leader of an African nation,...
...you will be responsible for the downfall of the British empire in Africa.
I am told that you no longer wish for me to honor my duty as your king...
...because of the color of the wife I have chosen.
Who do you think will accept you?
You belong to the whites but they won't want you either.
I am ready to serve you because I love my people, I love this land...
...but I love my wife.
It is time for us to create a new nation,...
...for us to be the masters of our own fate.
It is time!